l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Monsieur Raymond couer à madame
la ministre de l'Égalité des territoires
et du logement vous avez la parole chers
collègue monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues depuis
longtemps nos efforts en terme de budget
se sont principalement
concentrés sur le développement de
nouveaux logement ne portant pas assez
d'attention aux logements anciens
aujourd'hui dans certaines villes
françaises la place vientnent à manquer
pour la création de nouveaux logements
alors que dans le même temps les
logements anciens moins attractifs pour
de futurs acquéreurs car souvent
manquant de confort se vided aujourd'hui
la législation autorise le primo
accédent à bénéficier du
PTZ+ lors d'une acquisition dans le parc
immobilier ancien mais les conditions
d'accès à ce prê préférentiel sont
draconiennes en effet l'administration
fiscale ne retient cette possibilité que
pour des travaux de réhabilitation très
lourds du type gros œuvres travaux sur
les fondations les planchés porteurs les
murs porteurs et les travaux de secondde
œuvre ce qui ne correspond pas forcément
à une bonne partie du patrimoine
immobilier vacant en France par ailleurs
il faut noter que si le primo accédent
achète un bien qui est vraiment très
dégradé et qu'il est éligible au PTZ+ il
ne peut à ce jour bénéficier des aides
de l'ANA avant 5 ans et cela alors que
compte tenu de l'état initial de son
bien il va devoir supporter des dépenses
considérables pour le réhabiliter cela
n'incite pas les jeunes ménages à
investir dans les centre ancien des
villes aussi ne serait-il pas
intéressant d'élargir le programme
habité mieux en faveur de la lutte
contre la précarité énerg énergétique au
ménag aux ressources dites majorées
c'est-à-dire qui ont environ 25000 € de
revenus imposable ils pourraiit alors
bénéficier des aides de ce programme et
l'impact du programme serait plus
important et plus généralement
pourriez-vous expliquer à la
représentation nationale les mesures que
le Gouvernement entend prendre pour
valoriser l'accession à la propriété
dans le logement ancien je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Pascal Canfin ministre chargé
du
développement monsieur le sénateur
permettra de répondre à la place de
Cécile Dufflot qui est retenu à
l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernement
est bien évidemment conscient des
difficultés que rencontrent les ménages
au moment d'envisager l'achat d'un
logement que ce soit un logement neuf un
logement ancien qu'il y ait des travaux
à réaliser ou non c'est d'ailleurs pour
cela que nous avons décidé d'engager un
plan ambitieux annoncé notamment le 21
mars dernier par le Président de la
République un plan structuré autour
autour d'une série de 20 mesures en
faveur de la construction et de la
rénovation énergétique des logements ce
plan s'ajoute aux réformes des
dispositifs concernant l'investissement
locatif et concernant l'accession à la
propriété vous l'avez mentionné
vous-même le PTZ+ qui modifications qui
sont intervenues à la fin de l'année
2012 et ces modifications renforcaient
des évolutions qui avaient été mis en
mise en place début 2012 d'ailleurs par
le précédent gouvernement l'idée est de
contenir la dépense publique et de
soutenir le secteur de la construction
c'est pour cela que le PTZ+ avait été
recentré sur le 9F tout en maintenant la
possibilité de bénéficier de ce
dispositif pour l'acquisition d'un
logement ancien dans le cadre de la
vente du parc social à ses occupants ce
recentrage sur le neuf a été maintenu
par ce gouvernement car il répond à la
nécessité de concentrer l'aide où elle
doit être le plus
efficace depuis le 1er juin 2012 en
outre un logement qui fait l'objet de
travaux de remise en œuf au sens de la
TVA peut également bénéficier d'un PTZ+
avec la même aide qu'un logement neuf
cette mesure répond aux objectifs de
réhabilitation des centres-villees que
vous avez mentionné et de lutte contre
l'étalement urbain et il s'appuie sur
des dispositions existantes pour
faciliter sa mise en œuvre par les
banques par ailleurs afin d'encourager
la réalisation de travaux d'amélioration
de la performance énergétique de ces
logements il est possible maintenant de
cumuler un PTZ+ avec un écoprê à tau Z0
sous réserve de non cumule des assiettes
de financement je reviens au plan qui a
été annoncé le 21 mars dernier par le
Président de la République il répond à
deux
objectifs évoqués pendant la campagne
présidentielle construire 500000
logements par an et assurer la
rénovation énergétique de 500000
logements par an concrètement les
ménages de la classe moyenne disposent
d'une prime de 1350 € pour réaliser des
travaux de rénovation énergétique et
cette aide s'ajoua s'ajoutera pardon à
des aides déjà existantes vous avez
mentionné le programme habitz mieux
celui-ci sera renforcé il fera l'objet
d'un relèvement des plafonds de
ressources les ménages modestes qui
auront acheté un logement ancien non
éligible au PTZ+ pourront ainsi
bénéficier des aides de l'ANA pour
réaliser leurs travaux les autres
mesures du plan permettront de réussir
son déploiement sur l'ensemble du
territoire mais aussi de simplifier les
normes de construction de raccourcir les
délais de procédure et de construire là
où les besoins sont les plus forts
notamment en
ville merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Raymon couder s'il
le souhaite monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi d'insister sur le fait que
on peut avoir les mesures intentions du
monde on peut avoir des dispositifs qui
sur le papier paraissent extraord
ordinaire et qui devrait normalement
porter des fruits il s'avère que les
conditions
d'éliggibilité sont tellement
restrictives que l'effet ne se fait pas
sentir sur le terrain et je pense
justement que quand on fera un premier
bilan des mesures qui ont été annoncées
on se rendra compte que ces dispositifs
ne sont pas utilisés tout simplement
parce que les conditions d'éligibilité
sont pas adapté
au public qui serait susceptible de de
pouvoir en profiter donc je crois qu'il
faut véritablement réfléchir à la
réalité du terrain